I've got smacked in the Oscars
by this Chris Rock Comes
Out Swinging firing back at Will Smith
one year after the slap heard round the
world
now a source tells E.T he said
everything he wanted to say and is ready
to move on I'm not a victim baby you
will never see me on Oprah or Gail
crying
you'll never see it
never gonna happen the comedian
addressed being slapped by Will at the
94th academy awards ceremony for the
first time publicly during his live
Netflix special selective outrage which
was taped in Baltimore some of Chris's
peers like Dana Carvey David Spade Dave
Chappelle and Arsenio Hall were in
attendance to show their support no
matter what goes down we support each
other but it wasn't until the end of the
special that Chris dove into that now
Infamous moment the people I didn't hurt
it still hurts
I got summertime ringing in my ears
summertime of course being Will's 1991
track
Chris poked fun at the difference in
size between him and will before getting
a little more personal referencing the
cheating rumors that surrounded will and
his wife Jada Pinkett Smith in June
2020. his wife was her son's
friend okay
now
I normally would not talk about this
but for some reason these put that
on the internet back in July 2020 will
joined Jada on her Facebook Watch series
red table talk where they talked
candidly about her entanglement with
August Alsina I was in a lot of pain and
I was very broken she hurt him way more
than he hurt me okay and who's he
struck Chris
a joke about Jada's shaved head jaina I
love you GI Jane too can't wait to see
it all right
Chris closed his set referring to an
earlier Oscars dispute with a couple
recalling how Jada said Chris shouldn't
host the Oscars because will wasn't
nominated for his role in concussion
amid the Oscar so white backlash in
2016. I am rooted for Will Smith my
whole life I root for this
Okay and now I watch emancipation just
to see him get whooped
as for why he didn't fight back after
the slap cause I got parents that's why
because I was raised
okay
I got parents
and you know what my parents taught me
don't fight in front of white people
after the performance A source told E.T
Chris was very focused on the comedy
special for the past year and his hard
work paid off now he can relax I'm just
glad to see after what happened and all
the trauma and stuff that he emerged
stronger I'm glad he's getting a chance
to be seen and appreciated the source
explained that the special was a big
deal not only because it was a live
streaming event which was unprecedented
but also because it was the first time
he addressed the slap in a meaningful
way he said everything he wanted to say
it was funny self-deprecating and
thought provoking this is a historic
moment now E.T Source says Chris is
ready to move on
[Music]